welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is episode 76 on
nfts you've probably heard the hype some
celebrity sells an nft for millions of
dollars
how is this possible isn't it basically
a jpeg what does it stand for can't you
just screenshot it what's the point
matt medved is a musician producer
current svp of digital content
at modern luxury and co-host of nft now
a podcast dedicated to content on nfts
he answered my questions and gave me the
details behind nfts
why this technology probably isn't just
a fad and how to create and sell and
purchase them what platforms to use
etc this type of information is
definitely something to know in my
opinion
given how important blockchain
technology is
please hit subscribe if you like this
content and want to see more
this episode is brought to you by
carnivore crisps
yes i had some sent to dubai and you can
see by my face that this excites me more
than it should
carnivore crisps make pure meat and salt
chips
they're better than chips this is a
healthy snack in a bag
and they're awesome if you find yourself
snacking this is actually a food
not just junk i would highly recommend
checking them out
go to carnivorecrisps.com and enter code
mp for 10 off that code doesn't work on
their subscription
just so you know these are so good
my favorite is the ribeye and the beef
brisket
but the chicken is damn good too
they also have liver if you want to get
some liver in they also do fish and
cuts other cuts of beef and pork they
have everything in chip form
i literally can't get enough of these i
would live off of them if i could
carnivorecrisps.com codemp
linked below i hope you enjoy this
episode
thank you for watching
i do eat these i'm obsessed with them
like really this is them check them out
okay enjoy the episode
matt medved welcome to my podcast it's
great to be here thanks for having me
michaela
thank you so much for coming on i've
been wanting to learn about
nifties i even know how to say them for
at least
it hasn't been actually that long it's
probably been a month um but
i'm really glad to talk to you can you
give a brief background about
who you are and what it is that you do
sure thing uh so i'm matt medved
i'm currently svp of digital content at
modern luxury
um previously editor-in-chief of spin
magazine and the founder of billboard
dance
and actually co-founder of nft now which
is a new nft focus podcast that we're
actually launching
later this week okay you're calling them
nfts
do people not say nifties cause i just
introduced the episode
like that they say both they say both so
nft is you know sort of the technical
term for it
um and then there's a number of
companies like nifty gateway
and there's a new on nifties that um
that they call them nifty thinking
that'll it's a little bit easier to say
so um they're pretty much mutually uh uh
interchangeable there's no wrong way to
talk about them
okay let's start off really slow uh
what is uh an nft or a nifty
sure um so just to dive right in
you know but keep it in the in the
shallow section yeah yeah
please do um nft just means non-fungible
token
um what that essentially means
fungibility just means that something is
pegged to a certain
dollar value so for example um
an example of a fungible token would be
uh
any of the other sort of
cryptocurrencies you hear about in the
news like a bitcoin or an ethereum
those ones you know at any time of any
day you can check and see
how much money a bitcoin is worth
us dollars euros japanese yen
um an nft is not fungible like that it's
not
pegged to a specific dollar value in
fact it's sort of
the way the best way to think about it
is like a unique sort of item or
unique sort of asset and we have to kind
of assign value to it
the same way that we assign value to
many things in in our culture which is
you know cultural significance scarcity
sentimental value uh and and so that's
that's just the
the um uh just the actual terminology
nft
um the best way that i've found to think
about it
is it's essentially um a
a piece of digital media um that is
being
uh tracked and transacted on
uh the blockchain and so for those who
don't
understand or know the blockchain is
sort of the technology
that uh underwrites this whole ecosystem
you know bitcoin was the first
cryptocurrency that established
this blockchain technology and the best
way to think about it is like
it's a it's a ledger a public immutable
ledger of transactions
every you know we've been transacting as
humans for
uh since since the stone age you know
with trading and all that
um we used to keep track on with cave
paint you know with cave paintings
um then we had accountants uh you know
then we had
um you know digital uh apps that would
help us with accounting
um the exciting thing about blockchain
technology is that it's all
transparent it's public it can't be
forged it can't be
attacked or edited and so um
now that we can keep track of payments
of digital currency
the exciting thing is with nfts we can
actually track
ownership of digital assets so for the
first time ever
you can actually prove ownership of of
like a unique digital piece of media
in the same way for example you know
with a piece of like crypto art
the same way that you would be able to
track the ownership history
of a physical piece of art it's the idea
of provenance which sort of is is very
important in the art
in the art world so um now if uh
if i drew a you know if i drew a
portrait of you right now
i made an nft of it and i put it on the
blockchain and then sold it for you to
install it to you for you know 0.01
ethereum
forever we there would be a record to
show that that token which represented
that doodle and drawing i i
drew of you um was created by me on this
specific date
um and was transferred to you for that
exchange
and no one can tamper or forge or uh
or you know or edit that um
so that's that's sort of like the that's
the technology that's
that's sort of powering this and and
creating
this opportunity okay so i've got a
bunch of pretty simple questions sure
um and and for anybody listening i
i have an intro to bitcoin and an
economics of bitcoin podcast that i did
about
eight months ago so those might be good
to listen to if you want to learn about
blockchain
or or bitcoin but let's start with
okay what's the difference between i
you can explain this what's the
difference between just a jpeg of
something
and an nft like aren't what some people
are selling
are they just jpegs on the blockchain
um that it's it would be a bit of an
oversimplification to say
that it is um but so the best way to
think about an nft
is almost as like a certificate of
ownership
uh that's tied to a token that
represents um
a digital piece of media which can be a
jpeg which can be uh uh
um okay so what what you're essentially
doing when you're when you're minting
um you know uh let's say for example my
portrait of you that i've drawn
it let's say it's saved as a jpeg on my
computer we essentially meant that we
create a token
a unique token that basically represents
that and the ownership of that jpeg
on the blockchain um and then
it it it does sort of it does sort of
function as okay
this is that this is that piece of media
so
you know a lot of people ask like well
can't i like right click and save it
like what's the difference
um yeah you can take a photo of the mona
lisa too
or you could make a photocopy of the
mona lisa you know you can actually buy
the mona lisa
on amazon for 53 you know it looks
exactly the same but
most people don't want to put that up in
their home right because
it the real value comes from owning the
real thing
and up until now before up until
recently
there was no way to prove what was the
real thing
for a digital asset um now there is so
you know if you know there's nothing you
know in fact a lot of people and
collectors and
and you know artists in the space will
say sure right click and save my piece
of art
put it as your as your background put it
up on twitter you're just spreading the
word about my artistry it's the same as
you know it's the same but but at the
end of the day the real value
comes to who actually owns it um a good
example to kind of that i find kind of
helps people wrap their heads around
this
to a degree is thinking about it as a
digital collectible
so like for example we've always agreed
you know long before i think either of
us were born that trading cards have
value right like baseball cards and and
the like i mean a mickey mantle card
cost 50 cents to make
but it costs four million dollars to buy
you know
because it's just a piece of card stock
the value comes from
the scarcity the cultural like cachet
that we put on that
and the fact that like mickey mantle has
a history and a legacy that matters to a
lot of people
so people are willing to pay millions of
dollars for this rare
you know 50 cent piece of card stock
because of what it represents
and because of that scarcity and the
fact that it is from an investment
perspective
and appreciating asset you know that's
probably going to be worth more in
in 10 years um it's no different with
with digital
uh tokens like and nfts
um and so you know it you think about it
it's like all right the only thing that
you have to
um kind of make the jump for is is
accepting the fact that something that's
purely digital
has value um and now that we can prove
that it's the real one it's we can prove
how scarce it is
uh and what's actually really cool and
this is not to get too far along the
uh down the road but one of the things
that excites me the most about it is
a you can't damage it by storing it
improperly which you certainly can do
with a mickey mantle card
b you can transfer it anywhere in the
world pretty much
relatively instantaneously and see
probably the most exciting thing
especially in the context of art and
with creators
is that because it's built on ethereum
uh
blockchain which has smart contracts you
can essentially
program the nfts to
uh give royalties back to the original
creators
after they're sold on the secondary
market so someone who creates a
a piece of art can share in that value
in perpetuity
okay that's very interesting so the
reason
just purely from a business standpoint
part of the reason that i'm
interested in this uh is because of who
my dad is and i was like i could just
there's some
there's some business to be made here um
given what i've seen people do so
i've got some questions one well let's
just start with this do you think it's
ever going to leave ethereum
or is it stuck on ethereum for some
reason that's a great question
um what's interesting is so ethereum has
the network effect it's got the majority
of nfts are created on ethereum
most people are using it um but you know
there are some other blockchains where
nfts have already started
um there there are people doing nfts
actually on bitcoin using the lightning
network
um it's a small subset um there are
people who are doing
nfts on cardano um which is sort of like
another
like a fast block chain that that was uh
that was kind of seen as an ethereum
competitor
and there's a couple like smaller like
fringe sort of
projects on other blockchains like tezos
polkadot
um but as for whether it's going to
leave ethereum i don't think so
and i don't and i think ethereum's going
to main uh remain sort of the
the uh industry leader um for nfts
purely because of of network effect it's
everyone's already using it
ethereum has become sort of this um this
uh
sort of this has become basically you
know the the currency of
of uh of that ecosystem also
it is worth mentioning um that uh
there's also the flow blockchain
which actually powers nba top shot which
is obviously a big
um where we talk about the idea of
visual collectibles so
dapper labs who created uh nba topshop
they previously created cryptokitties
which was one of the first
uh ethereum blockchain projects and
um the block like ethereum like wasn't
even wasn't ready for it back then so
it'll actually like because people were
so we're using it so much it actually
clogged up the networks and like created
crazy
like gas fees and so they actually um
they actually are using their own
blockchain flow that they created for
uh nba top shot and they have plans
actually to move cryptokitties
over to that too so you will perhaps see
some other
um blockchains but i think ethereum
far and be like is far and beyond like
the leader in the in the sector and
and i think with the network effect it
enjoys i don't see it
like losing its position as the front
runner there
okay i i wondered because i don't know
much about this i was wondering why it
was on ethereum and not on bitcoin given
how much bigger bitcoin is but you said
there's more ease of coding or something
yeah so
the best way to describe that and you
know there are certainly people who
uh belong to different camp they're like
on different sides of the debate and
who might you know have their own
perspective but um as someone who like i
you know i
have bitcoin i have ethereum i think
they're both great for for various
reasons but
um you know the ethereum was the first
to implement
smart contracts um which is the
technology that really allowed
for um tokenizing um
these uh you know and creating like
these sort of marketplaces around
um tokenized media um but you know
there the if you go into the history of
nfts there are definitely some examples
that
developed on on bitcoin first there's
actually um
there was a like a trading card game
called rare pepes that was uh
it that was in like 2016 on on the
bitcoin blockchain so
um but but yeah i'd say it you know it
was really the smart con
the fact that ethereum established smart
contracts um
that that that was able that it was able
to sort of like build these
decentralized applications uh more
easily on that on that blockchain
okay so how difficult
let me see how do i phrase this is this
something anybody can learn how to do
like um do you have to hire an artist in
order to convert something into
into i guess an nft or to code
that or are there platforms that like
allow someone who doesn't know what
they're doing should they just do it how
hard is it for someone who doesn't know
what they're doing
like me for instance it's it's a great
question um
look i it's the the answer is it's never
been easier but i think there's still a
learning curve
that's very real um you know uh
so for example if you wanted to mint um
right now to my knowledge when we're
talking about the most like
you know the the main platforms um
if you wanted to mint an nft right now
um
it could be any piece of media um if
it's an open platform so for example uh
just
so people have some frame of reference a
lot of people have heard about nifty
gateway which is a really big platform a
leading one
that's a curated platform so no one can
just go there and just
put something on the blockchain there
they need to contact the team
schedule like be accepted uh schedule a
drop
you know so they that's a closed
platform but then there are ones like
openc
and wearable um that are open platforms
and so
anyone who has a a metamask wallet which
is sort of the ethereum wallet that that
is has become probably the most popular
option for for um
for navigating these it's a plugin that
you can download uh
for google chrome for for safari for any
of those browsers
um anyone who has that wallet set up
can upload uh an nft and so that that
nft could be
um and it does vary sometimes by
platform but in theory it could be
anything it could be a screenshot
it could be a piece of audio it could be
a voice note
it could be um you know a photo you took
of a
of a painting it could be um a selfie
you know like
in theory it could be any type of of
media
but it's in in reality it ends up being
dictated by obviously
certain platforms have rules and and
regulations because they're you know
they also they're copyright issues
and then also um you know there's also
you know
best standards and and all that and um
but so like for example
let's say that we let's give the example
of like let's say that you you drew
you drew a drawing right now and wanted
to make it an nft um
and like you know you took a high-res
photo of that drawing you had you had
that jpeg on your computer
you could go to a site like wearable or
open c
and mint that as an nft um it would
require
uh you to have some ethereum on hand uh
because there there are costs some costs
associated with minting an nft it's just
there are gas fees for using the
ethereum network and and the like so
it i've found that it kind of depends on
where
you're like the ethereum network
depending on on what the fees are based
on its usage
um it can be as much as like 75 to 100
potentially to mint an nft sometimes it
can be less
um but you could you know in the span of
a couple hours or less
you could get that um that phone you
know that that that drawing that you did
um minted as an nft on one of those
platforms
um so it it is it is possible for
for anyone to create one um as long as
they
have some ethereum and and have that set
up which can be a bit of a learning
curve for people because not everyone
who's interested in this space is crypto
native
so and i don't one thing that i always
you know i i started dabbling in crypto
back in 2013. um and you know
oh you know i mean i was a student then
so it's not like i had tons of capital
or anything but
but you know i i was i was dabbling and
i was playing around and i was learning
the
you know the the technology and the
ecosystem and
i um you know i i i remember
it being a really big learning curve for
me like i remember
pouring over the bitcoin white paper and
like and the platforms were much tougher
then too
but it was still a big learning curve
and so there are two learning curves
here there's the crypto
learning curve and then there's like the
nft art learning you know the crypto art
learning curve
both of which like i think are
significant and so
you know that's why i've been trying to
you know like help out
help people as much as possible and and
you know because
uh it's easy to forget once you've been
in in the space for for long enough it's
like oh yeah just like start a meta mask
and you know send it to send the
ethereum to that wallet and
and mint the nft it's like what was that
english you know what i mean yeah
a lot of people i recognize that a lot
of people um
it you know haven't been in the space
before and to me actually that's one of
the most exciting things about nfts
is that i think it's bringing in a lot
of new people who otherwise like you
know
bitcoin and all and ethereum and
cryptocurrencies and all that didn't
really
excite you know they didn't understand
it or it didn't really like you know
it didn't really um you know what's the
word it wasn't compelling to them or
it didn't inspire them but but art is a
different thing music is a different
thing
culture is a different thing and so i
think what we're seeing is through nft
is
i think main the crypto itself is
starting to go a bit more mainstream
but that comes with i i think if for
people who are in the space like
i see i feel like it's a responsibility
to like help ensure that people who are
new to the space
um you know have the right resources
have the right uh are shown
the right way to do things and and
because you know i i want everyone to
have a good experience
that's nice um i i'm a believer in it so
i you know i wouldn't want to see people
get burned or you know
get get uh taken advantage of so yeah
that that's fair uh when i started kind
of dabbling in bitcoin there was
definitely a learning curve it was
really annoying like really annoying and
it it was more recent so it wasn't like
2013 platforms
i looked at it then and i just i didn't
even bother i was like this is
impossible
um transferring yeah um okay
okay so for open sea and wearable
yeah can you um yeah let's start with
this one
can you code these rules into the
nifties or nfts like
um that you make a certain amount of
money each time it's sold or that
there's only one of these
can you code that in on those platforms
absolutely you can
um so what you can do is when for
example when you mint an nft on an open
c or
a wearable um you can set sort of like
the the royalty percentage
uh that will go to the original um
creator
industry standard has been kind of like
10 to 20 you know
um but you know you could in theory as
the creator you could set it higher
um and and then you can also um
like you can so you can choose whether
it's you know as you're admitting if
you're if you're minting it as a one of
one or if you're minting it as a one of
100 or
or however it is um but um
the one thing to be aware of is uh the
way that everything's coded in the
technology right now
if if that nft gets gets transferred to
a different
uh platform or you know if it gets like
taken example from
you know uh a uh for example if it gets
taken from like a super rare and gets
put on openc and then sold through openc
um there's there isn't currently the
capability for that royalty percentage
to to be transferred cross-platform um
that's something that that we're you
know the people in the space are hoping
to solve but it's uh
something that is very that's very good
to know that seems important
indeed okay so what i've heard in the
news is a lot about nifty gateway
um that seems to be so the reason people
go on that is that because they have
marketing capabilities or because it's
like
you said it's curated so is that mainly
for the marketing capabilities or
what or is it because you got on so it
has more value because you're on nifty
gateway or what
so here's what i'd say like i would say
nifty gateway is the leading platform
currently um i think they have the most
eyeballs they have the most
uh you know used or sort of like focused
on it um
aside from i'm not i'm not counting nba
top shot because that's a whole nother
ecosystem that's a you know they
actually have the most users of any nft
platform but
that's a very different thing it's
trading cards versus digital art and
so funny um but so the thing about nifty
is
um i i always i kind of refer to it's
like it's the most hype
platform it's like if you have a nifty
drop you're gonna have a lot of eyeballs
on it
from people who may not have known your
your art before
um so it's a huge exposure opportunity
um
and a lot of people and also you know
they're only
a certain number of drops per day um and
you know
you you have some of the biggest artists
on earth dropping on nifty you know we
just had the weekend
uh yeah nft this past this past week
uh again i think he did uh more than two
million in sales you know and so
it's it's um so nifty's kind of like
that that
main platform but the thing is is
there's also a lot of demand to get on
it
um because you know it's it is sort of
like
you know if you it is it is a really big
opportunity for
for uh for artists and musicians and the
like and so
they have a ton of demand they only have
so many slots so there's definitely a
bit of a of a backlog that they're that
they're working through
um to to you know to
kind of curate and make sure that
they're they're putting up the the right
mix and so
um you know i i think it's it's probably
a i don't want to speak for their team
in terms of curation but i i imagine
that they
they they weigh a number of different
factors like you don't say no to the
weekend
obviously like wanting to drop on your
platform but also like
they have a good mix too of like there
are a number of like crypto art ogs who
like
you know we may not you know if people
who aren't in that space may not know
their names but they're
you know really they were early adopters
and have built a real following in the
crypto space um so there are definitely
some artists like that who are
you know they they want to make sure
it's like a good mix of of new entrants
to the space and also people who have
been kind of like paying their dues in
it
okay um from what you've seen is because
when i first started seeing well
basically it come up in the news
a lot of it were pictures and now it
seems to be short videos
so have things changed slightly from the
beginning or was this always the norm
and that we're just seeing in the news
now
um well you know i think people have
been doing short videos for
for before since before the um the sort
of like mainstream explosion in interest
and attention but i do think that
i think as time is going on and more
people are getting used to the format
they're seeing
new and interesting ways to to do things
on there um
one example um that i always i think is
a great example it's actually how i got
into nfts
um my my good friend uh blau the dj
you may have seen his name three lau um
i've known him for years since our
billboard dance days and
um i saw that uh he was
um minting these short form video
clips with music uh as nfts
um with in collaboration with a visual
artist named slime sunday and this was
probably
back in like the fall of last year you
know so um
well definitely before like the
mainstream boom of attention
and i asked him about it and it's
actually it was it was really cool it
was like 30 to a minute
uh long music clip so like like these
really cool
loops and the like that you know and
paired with like a really compelling
like short video and visual and um
blau would then go on obviously if he
saw the headlines he
you know made history in terms of
tokenizing the first full-length album
had an 11.7 million dollar uh nft uh
album auction for that
um he's been a believer in the space for
a long time and um but
but even even you know before this he
was like they were doing like shortened
video clips too
so it i think it really depends you'll
you'll see photos still photos you'll
see like animated sort of gifs
um if you look at one of the big artists
who's actually
seeing a real market kind of like a big
market for them right now is a guy named
xcopy
um and he was one of the first uh
artists to
release excuse me not music visual art
on super rare um which is another one of
the curated platforms and
um and his were like gifts they were
essentially these like it was like gif
art
you know these sort of like really short
repetitive video clips um
kind of futuristic in nature and uh
and now his his his art is is really uh
has a big market
um so so video's been a part of it but i
i think
um one thing you're going to see uh is
like right now a lot of platforms have
file size limitations and there's also
you know i think
and and i think you know there's also
costs associated with doing
you know bigger uh one so so you're not
you're not really seeing
full-length tv shows or movies as nfts
but
i think in the future that that might be
possible so okay
um what's a gas fee you mentioned it
earlier
yeah yeah so um essentially
it's and you know it's it can be
a bit tough to explain but basically um
in
as you know i would recommend uh whoever
whoever is listening to check out
probably your previous
um uh podcast on on bitcoin and
blockchain technology
um just so they have a bit of
understanding on like the concept of
mining
um and sort of this this network that
exists of
of um because it's the same in a sense
for ethereum
in that uh there's a network uh
and there's essentially a fee that
accompanies transactions sent to the
network
um and that term is just called gas it
it actually
doesn't have anything to do with real
gas it's not even actually related to
any
increased energy consumption it's just
essentially the cost of doing business
on
the ethereum network to like to keep
things to keep the things going yeah
yeah you can't just continually upload
jpegs you make in hopes that
one will become a million dollar project
it's
they charge you money yeah but you would
need to exactly you would need to
uh you need to pay the the cost of of
minting and transacting to get those up
there
so yeah yeah it's not a that would be a
rate limiting step for sure
okay i've also heard somewhere i read
people complaining about the environment
and how this is bad
bad for the environment somehow do you
know anything about that
yeah look you know i think that the
issue is less
with with uh nfts
and um and then it is
um proof of that there are essentially
like there's
there are blockchains that are proof of
work versus um proof of stake
um proof of work blockchains like
bitcoin and ethereum's current
uh incarnation um do have a like the
proof of work does create uh
more of a co2 footprint than a
proof-of-stake model ethereum is
actually moving to
proof-of-stake which is a much much less
um
you know it's it uh it's it's much less
in terms of like energy consumption
but i don't know how how is that
just like how's that energy consumption
compared to
producing like material goods yeah i can
tell you
it's it's tiny and so that's the thing
is that i think that
the there has been a distortion in the
media around
um you know around just how bad
any of this is for the environment um
yeah like there are a lot of
sensationalist headlines and one of the
big issues is that the headlines often
focus on
transactions and they act they say
sending one nft transaction
is the equivalent of this carbon
equivalent of doing this
but what they actually ignore is that
that's not how ethereum works
um even if you never sent any nft
transactions it would be the exact same
energy cost
so ethereum has the way that it works in
just in terms of using ethereum and
blockchain
it's a it's a fixed uh amount of energy
no matter how it's being used um and and
so
it's really i think disingenuous to
demonize
artists for um using this this network
to um you know create opportunities
to monetize their creative vision um
when
when it's when the nfts themselves are
not in any way actually adding to that
um the other thing that's really
important to to mention
is that out of our entire carbon
footprint ethereum represents point
zero two percent and that's the entire
ethereum blockchain of which crypto
nfts are or even smaller fraction just
for
just for example um agriculture is more
than eleven percent
industrial is almost six percent land
use change in forestry is more than six
percent you know waste is more than
three percent
and then you get into like the 73
percent that's industrial commercial
residential transportation
aviation road and shipping all of which
by the way
when we're talking about doing physical
art or
physical things like there's shipping
costs there's there's all of these
things that play in too
so i think it's really important like
for context
the entire ethereum network has about
the same carbon footprint
as youtube so like one company you know
and and so
and so it's it's it's been blown a bit
out of
out of proportion um because at the end
of the day
you're looking at at something where
it's it's less than
it's even less than 0.1 percent of of
the entire carbon footprint and it's
even smaller fraction of that
is nfts but i think you know and so
that's one thing that
that you know been trying to help people
understand
and what's amazing is as ethereum
transitions from proof of work to proof
of stake
that small sliver of a percent is going
to get even smaller
okay yeah i was that that all
vaguely makes sense um
one of my questions was going to be do
you think this is going to continue
but you've made a pretty made a pretty
good argument that it should especially
with the fact that
it's like it's kind of like baseball
cards i mean it's printed on paper
so but you could display nfts on some
sort of screen if you wanted to
display them and if the screen broke you
just display it on a different screen or
a bigger screen or a smaller screen
that's that's kind of cool so the ones
that
the ones that are the most popular does
it seem to be random based on how
popular the person
is does it seem to be based on the
quality of the art
are collaborations more popular like is
there any pattern here
it's a great question and just before i
jump into it to address the point you
were just mentioning like
yeah i know a lot of collectors who for
example will display their nftr on like
videos these like chic looking video
screens
but but also worth mentioning and this
is obviously a bit more of a deep dive
which you don't need to
into but um as we move more towards a
digital
first world um with augmented reality
and virtual reality
um there are actually whole vr worlds
being built on the blockchain called
which we kind of collectively refer to
as the metaverse and there are people
there are collectors there who are
literally building art galleries
in the nvr full of nfts and crypto art
it's happening already um in fact you
can go visit some of them on platforms
like decentraland cryptovoxels
omnium space so um there's gonna be a
lot of opportunities to
to kind of show off your nfts and your
art in in i think various digital places
and
one thing i always ask people when they
ask about like well where do i put it
i'm like well do you spend more time
looking at screens or your walls
yeah whoa that is so cool but also
really scary
okay we're living in the future so um
okay
wait okay i'll i don't remember what i
asked before but
how do you exist popularity but okay
let's do popularity first i'll just
write down my next question
yeah well one thing that's really
interesting is that um
you know i i think that what what many
have found is that
celebrity only gets you so far uh in in
this new sort of web three uh ecosystem
economy
um look you know as i mentioned like
blau before
um blau you know obviously a very
successful
dance and electronic music dj but a lot
a lot of much bigger names
have since entered the space and and
made a fraction of what he made
um and part of that is because there is
a real community
that has been formed around nfts um
and and especially it's like sort of a
medium native community
um and i think uh you know obviously the
using blouse an example they see him as
a pioneer someone who really
pushed like pushed the envelope and made
history with music nfts
um and so they can they they can it's a
pretty savvy community they can tell the
difference between
someone who's crypto native and really
like in it for for
the right reasons and someone who's just
trying to do a cash grab you know
um oh no so there's a lot of that
happening now and
and so um but you know i think so
the fact that i i would say that um look
if
you have built a community around your
brand
whether it is a singer
a sports figure a podcast host whatever
it might be
there's an opportunity for you uh with
nfts i think
but uh you also also
need to i think may you know that in
order to
i think to achieve longevity in the
space
um there's a lot of value in
um getting into that community getting
to know the the people in that and
the players and the artists and the
figures in in that community
um and uh you know kind of like you know
making it clear that that you're there
to build in a sustainable
way versus just a a a cash grab
uh way and and i think what we've seen
is we've seen some really big artists
names i won't mention but we see some
really big artists do very nominal
outreach and very
you know you know like just like drop
something on nifty gateway or whatever
um and have their draw and their some of
their drops have flopped because
even though they're huge outside of that
space they didn't they didn't spend the
time trying to
um cultivate any relationships within
the space uh
so it it's it's always you know i think
important to be
uh medium native i've had a lot of
artists reach out to me actually about
nfts and i always i actually always
recommend them to
to get into the space spend time
listening start collecting you know you
can buy and if
like we obviously we see all the
headlines about these you know millions
and millions of dollars but you can buy
nfts for very inexpensive as well like
i've bought 25
nfts you know i bought like i bought
even cheaper ones and
i i think like you know clubhouse and
twitter are two
very very um important platforms for the
nft community
there's a lot of like nft rooms in in
clubhouse
that's a good idea yeah and and what i
found is it's a very welcoming community
so you know i think that everyone who's
who's in it wants to see it grow
wants want to see artists and creatives
empowered
um so if you approach it you know if
you're even if you're not
don't have a great a huge background on
in crypto or an nft zone but if you
if you kind of uh approach it with it
with an open mind and and and
be willing to listen and all that and
and your your heart's in the right place
with it
um you know i've i've seen a lot of
people who uh
and big big artists and and talent uh
get get embraced and
and achieve success in the space okay
the bitcoin community is kind of like
that
i found like especially on twitter like
super super friendly people
uh okay um what are my questions
okay these uh so you said augmented
reality galleries
what's the difference between the art
galleries okay what's the difference
between augmented reality and
and virtual reality it's a great
question so
augmented reality um is sort of like the
idea of
like a layer um a layer over
like our existing reality so like if you
were wearing for example like
um glasses that that could then you know
if you were to you know and again i i
don't work directly in that space so i
don't
want to get too technical or give any
examples there but like
if you were wearing essentially like
glasses that had like an ar component
which would allow you
when you were you know like if you would
have like google maps on the go like in
glasses like
what google like google glass is trying
to do and things like that like that's
example of ar
it's like augmenting our existing
reality with
sort of like these digital inputs and
then vr is like
if you're wearing like an oculus headset
and you're fully immersed
in a in a digital world a virtual world
okay and so they're building galleries
that you can visit with the oculus
headset
that's right and i mean you can you can
visit them in your
like in your uh google chrome browser as
well it's just not like the best
like a user it's not the best like
viewing experience you know
uh it's definitely much much better when
you're when you're in it
um but but you could go to for example
one of those platforms and type in the
coordinates and
like you could you could you know browse
around in there on
on your computer it's just it's a world
of difference when you're like actually
immersed in it
okay so if you have a bunch of i bought
an oculus headset
and i haven't like explored enough with
it um
i'm worried about the learning curve i
think of just putting it on but anyway
if you have a bunch of people with these
oculus headsets is there a social aspect
like can you see other people in there
or
are you by yourself i think that's why i
haven't used it i'm like i don't want to
be by myself
the augmented reality sounds a lot more
interesting but can you see other people
in the spaces you can you can
and in fact you know i think over the
past year
with kovid um and and so many people
being stuck at home
and and not able to to um socialize in
the same way
um you've actually seen an uptick and
growth in that i actually think it
pushed
everything vr ahead by like five years
um similar to like the success with
clubhouse where it's like
you know we're all stuck at home like
drop in audio chat is make so much sense
to connect with people um i know it was
a game changer for me during quarantine
to be able to
just connect with people like that a lot
of people are doing the same thing
in in vr um you're one step ahead of me
because i still don't have my own oculus
headset but i um
but i'm like i'm i'm really interested
in exploring the vr
aspect of the space more yeah i can see
how augmented
reality could really take off too
because then you have the social aspect
but then you have these
special glasses that allow you to see
another layer that not everybody else
sees
like that's pretty there's no way that's
not taking off
even just for fashion you'd be like yeah
well i own the
these digital shoes you can't see them
because you can't afford this maybe i
don't know how people are gonna
look at it like the intersection of the
of this technology and fashion is gonna
be fascinating
um they're actually there's actually a
really a really great person in the
space uh she's a great voice her name is
lady phoenix i i encourage people to
follow her on
on clubhouse because she hosts really
great rooms but she actually started
crypto fashion week
and um was doing a ton of really
interesting uh
really interesting things on that front
that's wild
okay yeah i mean it wasn't just
even social media there was like i've
had a lot of growth i mean i started a
podcast but i think
part of the growth was because people
are stuck at home trying to see other
people and so
everyone's on their screens which
hopefully doesn't last forever but
it's definitely made things more popular
even bitcoin
i'm sure that that was partly because
you know the instability around and
everyone's like
well maybe crypto's more stable looks
like it might be
uh okay
for these pieces of art that go for
millions um
are those generally because they're
selling multiple pieces or are those
single pieces
it's a great question oftentimes
the highest priced pieces are the
scarcest so there's
usually the one of ones um so like when
you see
uh like like that people the people uh
piece that that sold for 69 million
obviously that was
a it was a collage of of all of the
pieces he had done
over you know a period of years but it
was one
piece one one of one um those tend to
command
the highest prices for individual pieces
um just like in the traditional art
world it's like
you know scarcity is king um and same
with collectibles you know
um but but one thing that's interesting
is like for uh example like on a nifty
gateway
you could do a drop that had multiple
pieces of artwork that are sold in
different ways
so for example you could have an auction
on a one of one
that might have the highest like price
tag for that one piece
but you could also do uh an open edition
for like a ten minute window of another
piece at a
a much lower price point but sell more
of those in aggregate that actually
could end up doing more money in total
if that makes sense
um for example blouse auction when he
did with a record setting one
was um 33 unique nfts
sort of you know like uh tied to this
album
um that he did in in an auction format
uh
and so the the the top two bids were i
believe 3.6 million and 3.5 million for
the top two
and then in aggregate those 33 were
worth
was it was 11.7 million total if that
makes sense
so who's who has this much money to
like buy this art who's buying these
just elon musk who's doing it he's the
only person behind this well let me
let me uh i think there's it's there's
no it's it's a really interesting
question because
um i know for actually in blouse case
the the top bidder was actually
a a guy outside the crypto space it was
john legere on the former t-mobile ceo
um but and so that's i think actually a
really interesting sign of
the traditionally wealthy getting more
into the space
but i think you know the to answer your
question
i think it really first started with
these crypt donated like the crypto
wealthy
the sort of crypto native whether they
were traders or investors or
people who made who who were very
successful in the crypto space
maybe sitting on billions multi millions
um
in bitcoin ethereum other
cryptocurrencies um and what's
interesting is prior to nfts there
wasn't
really a way for them to stake out their
own identities in the same way as there
may be now if that makes sense a lot of
these
a lot of these people were sort of uh
anonymous
and what's interesting with nfts is it's
created this
space where i think like the crypto rich
can can can become patrons of the arts
in the same way that like the
traditionally wealthy have done for
generations which is like
patrons of the arts it's a bit of a
status thing for sure it's a
it's a you know it it's part it kind of
it comes with that
like sort of like establishing that
brand for yourself um
but what's also really interesting is
that and i think it really worth noting
is that a lot of people who got rich in
crypto
are not trying to move it into fiat
because they're not trying to create
taxable events
you know um and a lot of them also are
big believers in this technology that's
the reason they were early
you know that they believed in this
technology um outside of its ability to
just
you know obviously you know make uh make
them rich
and so what's interesting is with nfts
is it gives it's an opportunity for
uh people to to be to make these sort of
moves and and
and um kind of build that kind of
identity for themselves as collectors
uh while not having to take it out of
the crypto ecosystem so
um you know what's interesting is that
uh you know
if if you think about it this way for
someone who's sitting on
a billion dollars of bitcoin and
ethereum three million dollars really
isn't that much
to support someone who has been
championing the technology
that you really believe in and has been
spearheading mainstream adoption
which is why i i mentioned in blau's
case
he is viewed as a pioneer in the space
he is viewed as someone who pushed music
nfts forward and
really spearheaded that time that that
at a time when a lot of people didn't
take it seriously and so
um one of the reasons that's one of the
reasons why he did so well
compared to you know other artists who
are traditionally bigger names
um and and i think it's it's you know
there's that community but
so it started with the crypto the crypto
collectors but
what's been really exciting to see is
now there are a lot of you know
i think a lot of new entrants to the
space um who don't necessarily fit that
that profile
and you've got and and there have also
been really cool
interesting success stories of people
who started with a couple thousand
dollars
you know wasn't even in the crypto space
but made the right made the right
moves and bought the right artists early
um and have been able to to create
significant um you know like life you
know i've been able to change their own
lives
uh you know with in that space so um
but but i know the last thing i want to
mention is that while a lot of the
headlines
focus on these massive like million
dollar
um you know sales what's actually more
exciting to me
are the much smaller but more frequent
sales that are happening kind of more
under the radar
every day day in and day out for artists
who otherwise never had that income
stream
what's super cool to me is that for
example
you know i come from the dance music
world uh having started billboard dance
i've known
a lot of visual artists who created
visuals for
you know like there's a guy in the space
named ness graphics who created tour
visuals for
uh travis scott martin garrix like some
of the top artists
but again at the end of the day he was
doing client work
he was wasn't really able to make a
living pursuing his own vision
right his own creative vision and now he
can actually create
these and he's been doing this these one
of one video like via
not vr but like video um like rendered
3d rendered
pieces and selling them for i've seen
him going
i've seen it i've seen him go from like
2 000 a piece to up to like
twenty thousand dollars a piece um once
he's been really building a following on
super rare
and that and now he has the ability to
pick and choose the client work he wants
you know he's actually making more money
significantly more money
pursuing his own creative vision and i
think that's super cool and i think
that's really empowering
for artists on every level and um to me
that's the real promise of nfts is that
you can directly monetize and you don't
necessarily need
millions of fans to you know what i mean
if you look at the streaming model
um it you you need millions and millions
and millions and
even billions of streams to even really
make significant money as an artist on
streaming platforms
um you and an agent
yeah yeah exactly and like and so but
what's interesting is
there's actually um you know there's a
theory it's like of like the idea of
like
the 1000 true fans so it's like if if
you have 1 000 true fans who will
buy anything you release uh subscribe to
your
uh podcast for whatever like you know
you know the reasonable pay tier or
or your sub stack or you know they'll
travel to see your show they'll buy your
merch
like you can actually have a sustainable
career as a creative
um with you don't need millions you just
need thousands
the issue is that we have trusted
centralized social media platforms
uh to connect with those fans and
they have been putting algorithms and
you know advertisements in the way of us
being able to do it we have to pay to
play
and i think nft technology is a way for
us
to cut out the middlemen for creatives
to cut out the middlemen
and be able to directly monetize from
their following in a really sustainable
way and so
it's as much as like yeah like you know
these these crazy headlines like
yeah like is that is that speculative is
there a bubble there
yeah probably but but you know this
technology
isn't going anywhere and what's really
exciting to me is how this technology
uh in a less flashy way is changing the
day-to-day
like realities and and careers and lives
of
of many like much like smaller like
lower tier
artists and creatives um who are now
able to create sustainable incomes
directly from their creativity that's so
satisfying to hear
have you said that multiple times before
that was a
it was a good i don't know if it was in
those words but you know i am
i'm definitely trying to to spread
spread the good word and you know to me
look i i work in media so i know how
media works and i know that
the headlines that get the most clicks
and the headlines are the most
sensational and the biggest dollar tags
yeah and and i i get it i get it so
that's why i
always want to make sure like there are
there are you know there are
so many more much smaller sales and
transactions happening that aren't
getting covered
day to day but they're they are like
changing artists lives and that's really
and that's that's what i that's why i
got into like music and media and the
like in the first place was about
uplifting artistry
so that's one of the reasons why i'm so
passionate about the application of this
technology in the creative space
yeah that's really cool i've never seen
any type of
media i guess really buzz
focused on artists as much as this i've
never seen that before
like it is quite amazing um if you have
time i have two more questions
sure sure let me see yep i'm good i'm
good okay
okay um are there rules so if
if you make an nft um
are there rules around like selling it
in the real world like if you uploaded
an album and you sold it
as an nft can you still sell it as a
record and sell it as a cd and sell it
online
it's a great question so technically
technically speaking
yes like you could for example you know
because what what you're doing with with
an nft is you're not
selling the ip you're not you know as we
said it think a bit of like a
certificate of ownership of the token
representing
this this piece of art or piece of media
whatever it is
um but at the end of the day you got to
maintain
your artistic credibility to have a
market right so if you
if you for example release a
um if you release a one of one if let's
say let's say we
we take that that uh that drawing that
you that you did you know you did this
drawing
um you put it up on wearable you're like
this is a one of one
um you know that's it's michaela
peterson's genesis nft which means it's
your first ever nft
um collectors love genesis nfts they
have you know it's like
you know it's like early work so it's
like you know you've you've said it's a
one of one
limited edition this is it um
and then you sell that and then hey you
if you were to upload multiple versions
of it be like psych
like there's actually gonna be a lot of
these yeah you would yeah you would
destroy your credibility as
in there but also if you had said like
this is a limited one of one
and you know i'm not gonna be selling it
in any other form and then they
went to your website and saw you were
selling prints yeah
or merch or something you'd probably get
out in the community and and your your
market would be affected quite adversely
it would be
uh so like there's i think there's a bit
of like a bond of trust
between um artists and and their
and their collectors and and patrons
there
um and it is really in artists best
interests
not to try and pull fast ones or
anything like that because it can
destroy their market
you know and their reputations
okay but so you're your artist friend
who tokenized an album yes does that
mean
he's not making money from his album on
other platforms
no no he still is so that's that's
what's really interesting about it is
that
um you know that album is it was
actually previously released he did this
around so this was like the like the
it was the last i'll be released i
believe it was three years ago and this
was like the
on like the third anniversary and so the
best way to think about it is like
he created 33 unique
digital collectibles commemorating the
album
if that makes sense that's the best way
to think about it it does
kind of yeah
same way as like let's say let's think
about this way like let's say
on the 25th anniversary of like the
beatles sgt peppers if like if they had
done
like some limited edition um
vinyl discs you know vinyl records that
were like
signed by them or you know what i mean
like like we'd be like oh those have
value like it's signed by the beatles
it's like the 25th anniversary like
those have value um it's the same idea
it's the same idea so it's it's not like
it's not like the the purchaser of
of it suddenly owns sergeant pepper's
the like the royalties or the
or the actual um you know the masters or
anything it's the same in this case
where like they essentially
purchased like these um you know these
these uh
nfts and actually in blouse case he
actually did
have physical vinyl uh pieces that
that they steady sent to each of these
people and that's something we've also
seen artists
do is sometimes accompany it with a
physical piece just to like
make it make it real for them you know
um but like
but but you don't have to do that
obviously and so so that to answer the
question
so essentially you know the the actual
right structures underlying that album
like who you know who owns the masters
who's getting the royalties the
publishing they were they were actually
unaffected
by this by the sale
okay i'm slowly wrapping my head around
this it makes sense and then it doesn't
make sense
then it makes sense again um okay i
think this is the last question
so you mentioned taxes and how some of
these people who have
millions of dollars um in cryptocurrency
are
spending it on art and i totally
understand how that would work
but so if
if you bought ethereum and then
purchased
nfts and then sold them and earned money
do you not pay taxes on that money
unless you pull out the ethereum
it's a great question it's a great
question there's still
you know i as a i'm not since i'm not a
lawyer who works
in on that specific space i definitely
don't want to give
like legal advice one way or another
because i i i think it's
it it's a really tricky thing right it's
tricky because
and this is this is across the board but
like you know the
these laws were written by people who
who had never conceived of this
of this technology existing you know so
i i think that and it's always been the
case that like the laws are
10 to 15 years behind like what's what's
happening and
which is why like there's a lot of um
competition about like what constitutes
a security when it comes to like digital
uh tokens and the like but um so usually
and and i think it varies by
by state somewhere to some in certain
places too but
um you know i i certainly like when you
sell
uh certainly if you if you sell an nft
uh
like and then you send and you put that
ethereum into
uh us dollars that creates a taxable
event and
there are um depending on how long you
held that asset
uh it could be taxed at your income rate
like his income rate or if it was held
for a long enough period it could be
treated like capital gains tax
um which is which is why there's a bit
of an incentive sometimes to
to hold if you prefer for longer if you
don't if you don't need that immediately
um but yeah like they're like right now
i think and i think it's really
interesting there's gonna be a whole
cottage industry on the legal side of
mapping out exactly how these laws apply
in the context of nfts
um because in certain cases it's not
quite clear
okay that was awesome uh thank you so
much
i think i i think i asked everything i
wanted to ask
where can people find you on social
media if they want to contact you or
follow you
for sure my all of my all of my handles
are at medved
m-a-t-t m-e-d-v is in victor e-d and
then
um yeah follow along at nft now because
we're going to be doing some really
exciting things there as well
cool i'll put those links in show notes
and below thank you so much for coming
on that was fascinating
yeah i really enjoyed it as well always
happy to talk about the space
you